wow yes another video that's a little
bit murdery and
by that i mean a lot murdery if that's
the sort of thing you're looking for
don't forget to check out my new podcast
the casual criminalist that puts out two
new episodes every week from serial
killers that haven't aged out of primary
school yet to
schizophrenic breakdowns and
bible-obsessed sociopaths my
writer callum is combing through the
graveyards of history like an absolute
weirdo and it's all in the name of
giving you some more sweet sweet
content so if you're looking for a good
true crime podcast that's casually done
why not give the casual criminalist a
try
there are links in the description below
and let's get into today's video
throughout the second half of the 1970s
there was a horrifying presence that
loomed over the north of england
so gruesome was this specter of death
that in the minds of many
he hearkened back to the country's most
notorious figure
jack the ripper this modern day
counterpart turned out to be just as
vicious and bloodthirsty which is why he
came to be known
as the yorkshire ripper
[Music]
the world at large was first introduced
the ripper on the 30th of october 1975
when the body of 28 year old scottish
mother of four wilma mccann
was found near her home in the suburb of
scott hall
in leeds yorkshire county in the north
of england she had been hit in the head
with a hammer
and stabbed 15 times in her stomach
chest
and neck due to the viciousness of this
crime over a hundred police officers
were assigned to catch the killer but
from the very beginning they showed
prejudice that ended up prolonging the
investigation
and causing yet more murders will mccann
was not exactly a stay-at-home mum she
was separated from her husband
and would sometimes go out partying
leaving her children in the care of her
eldest daughter since it was too early
to know that her death was the work of a
serial killer police
looked into her private life thinking
that the culprit may have been someone
who knew her personally they initially
described her as having
several boyfriends and from there rumors
appeared that this was simply a
euphemism for prostitution the gossip
was repeated by the media
and the police never really bothered to
correct them so soon enough it became
accepted as fact that will mccann had
been a prostitute
even though this had never been proven
conclusively a few months later the
killer struck again
this time the victim was 42 year old
emily jackson whose
body was found the morning of january
the 20th 1976
on an abandoned industrial estate in
leeds like will mccann
jackson's killer first struck her in the
head with a hammer to incapacitate her
but then he stabbed her over 50 times
most likely with a sharpened screwdriver
as if that was not enough overkill he
then proceeded to
stomp on her body with his foot this
actually gave the police
their first clue regarding the identity
of the killer because
he left a boot impression on emily
jackson's thigh it belonged to a
wellington boot size seven later
identified by the pattern as
a dunlop warwick model emily jackson
lived in
morley west of leeds with her husband
sydney and three children the family was
in dire financial straits after sydney
jackson's roofing business went under so
as a last resort his
wife had turned to prostitution the
jacksons were in the habit of traveling
to leeds in their van which emily used
to meet clients while her husband waited
for her in a nearby bar despite the
extreme escalation in violence police
were confident from the outset that
emily jackson and will mccann had been
murdered by the same man however they
also became convinced that the culprit
was motivated by a hatred of prostitutes
this
plus the ferocity of the crimes
immediately drew comparisons to the
country's most
infamous killer jack the ripper soon
enough the media had the perfect name
for this new predator
the yorkshire ripper
[Music]
the ripper did not kill again for over a
year on february the 5th 1977 the body
of 28 year old irene richardson
was found in another suburb of leeds
called chapel town
like the others she had been struck
repeatedly in the head with a hammer and
then stabbed multiple times it looked
like the killer
left another important clue behind tire
tracks which
looked like they belonged to a van or a
medium-sized sedan
police actually managed to track down
the make and compiled a list of 26
models of cars that
were fitted with these tires it sounded
like a promising lead but
in the end it resulted in over 100 000
compatible cars in
west yorkshire alone the victim's story
was similar to that of emily jackson
broken homeless irene richardson was
also another woman who had resorted to
prostitution
out of desperation unlike the previous
year the ripper was very active in 1977.
he killed again on april the 23rd just
two months after the murder of irene
richardson this time he ventured away
from leeds and killed in bradford a city
about 14 kilometers away
there was another significant departure
from his usual modus operandi as he
committed the crime
inside the victim's apartment we don't
know if this was coincidental or if he
was actively trying to make it look like
the work of another killer but it was
not enough to fool the authorities not
only was the killing method the same
but again he left a size 7 wellington
boot print at the scene
the victim was another cool girl called
patricia atkinson who
usually went by tina and would regularly
visit pubs to pick up clients and
take them to her apartment this further
reinforced the police's theory that the
killer was acting out of a hatred for
prostitutes a
theory that they would refuse to dismiss
even when presented with clear evidence
that pointed to the contrary that
evidence came two months later on
june 26 1977. sixteen-year-old
jane mcdonald was returning to her home
in chapel town after a night of dancing
with her friends
it was late at night and jane had missed
the last bus and could not find a taxi
so she had to walk back she was attacked
by the ripper and her body was dumped in
a playground where she was discovered by
some children the next morning her
injuries
made it clear that jane had been killed
by the same man who killed all the other
women however both the police and the
media treated her very differently
in their eyes jane mcdonald was not like
the others words like innocent and
respectable were used whenever
describing her which
of course heavily implied that this was
not the case for the other victims
it was even suggested that the ripper
had made a terrible mistake by
killing jane mcdonald as he probably
confused her with the prostitute
since she was out alone at night for
better or worse
this kind of inflammatory speech had an
effect on the british public
a lot more people were getting involved
with the case some who shared the same
prejudices as the police and the media
felt outrage at the violent murder of
jane mcdonald in a way they did not for
the other victims
others now realize that no woman was
safe so simply being an upstanding
citizen did not guarantee protection
from the ripper there was also a lot of
anger at the police for their inability
to catch the ripper for
their victim blaming and for their
strategy of preventing more killings by
making women stay at home after dark
these actions directly led to the
appearance of
the reclaim the night protests as part
of england's women's liberation movement
the first march was held in november
1977 in leeds after police suggested a
curfew for women
[Music]
the ripper's next attack occurred in
july of the same year but there was
something different about this one
the victim survived on july the 9th
maureen long left her home in farsley
and
traveled to bradford for a fun saturday
night out she visited a few pubs and
then went dancing in a club
after the night's festivities had ended
she went looking for a taxi but a white
car pulled up instead and
offered her a ride maureen accepted and
got inside the car not knowing that she
was being driven
by the yorkshire ripper after taking her
to a secluded area the driver attacked
maureen long with a hammer
but she was incapacitated he dragged her
out of the car and began stabbing her
fortunately for maureen there was a dog
nearby that started howling which
prompted the attacker to drive away in a
hurry
before he could finish his murderous
deed a night watchman spotted the car
speeding away but did not actually see
maureen's body
it wasn't until the next morning that a
few women found her
barely clinging to life as you will soon
discover maureen long was not the first
ripper victim to survive her encounter
but she was the first
that the police actually bothered to
investigate as part of the case
right before she went in for emergency
surgery detectives were by her side to
note down whatever details she could
remember
about her attacker she managed to
provide a decent description
white guy in his mid-30s large build
with light brown hair
it was a lot more than they had before
and it got even better when the night
watchmen identified the car
as a ford cortina mark ii that was the
same model
often used by taxi drivers even before
this revelation investigators are toyed
with the idea that the killer might
drive a taxi
it gave him a good reason to be out
alone at night it also meant that
he had good knowledge of the area and
would know where to find prostitutes
and where to take them based on this new
information the police began looking
into taxi drivers more aggressively and
they even found a good suspect his name
was terry hawkshaw he hit the
description he lived with his mother
close to where the murders occurred and
he had poor alibis for the night when
they happened detectives started
surveilling him 24
7 and even served a warrant to search
his home of course
in hindsight we know they didn't find
anything because hawkshaw
was innocent meanwhile the real killer
was still prowling the streets unimpeded
in a car that was not a ford cortina
mark
ii it was actually a ford corsair all
that effort had been wasted because the
night watchman had made a mistake
when he id the vehicle the ripper's last
murder of 1977 occurred on october the
1st when
he ventured farther off the beaten path
and traveled to manchester where he
picked up a working girl named
jean jordan a 20-year-old scottish
runaway who resorted to prostitution to
feed her family he drove to a secluded
vacant lot between allotments and killed
her by smashing her head repeatedly with
a hammer the ripper
then went home but soon realized he'd
made a mistake
he had paid jordan with a brand new five
pound bill which could have been traced
back to him
the killer hesitated to go back to
retrieve the note fearing that the
police would be around
however when an entire week had passed
without any mention of the ripper's
latest victim in the newspapers he
concluded that the body had not yet been
found and
it was safe for him to return he was
right gene jordan's lifeless figure was
still where he left it but
he could not find her purse filled with
rage the ripper took out the knife and
unleashed his anger on the victim once
more
mutilating her already decaying body
with vicious swipes
afterwards he gave up on the bill and
went home the body was discovered a day
later as this time the ripper left it in
a more obvious place
it was actually found by a zen 23 year
old dairy worker named bruce jones who
went on to become a soap actor
most famous for his role on coronation
street in later interviews the actor
admitted that he was investigated as a
possible suspect in the killings
following the discovery the police also
found the purse with a five pound bill
and were able to trace it to the shipley
branch
of the midland bank it had been
dispersed as part of payroll but there
were 34 possible firms to investigate
police interviewed around 5 000 workers
but nobody stood out
among them was one peter sutliff who was
questioned twice by detectives but
managed to ease their suspicions by
providing an alibi the yorkshire ripper
evaded the law once more the killer
ended the year with another attack where
the victim survived on december 14th he
picked up marilyn moore in leeds and
took her to an empty lot he began his
attack as always with a vicious hammer
blow to the head but it was a dog who
saved the day again
by barking loudly and prompting the
ripper to leave the scene a couple found
more and called an ambulance
she lived through her ordeal and even
provided police with a sketch of her
attacker who
introduced himself as dave but there was
still no luck in catching him the
yorkshire ripper
entered the new year still a free man
[Music]
after having his deadliest year so far
the ripper showed no signs of slowing
down in 1978.
he killed two women in january 22 year
old yvonne pearson and 18 year old helen
ritka although yvonne was killed first
on january 21
the murderer hid her body under an old
sofa and she wasn't discovered until
march
something else of note happened around
that time something that took the case
in the completely wrong direction
prolonged the investigation and allowed
the ripper to claim more lives on march
the 8th the police received a letter
purported to be
from the killer it started like this
dear sir
i'm sorry i cannot give my name for
obvious reasons i am the ripper
i've been dubbed a maniac by the press
but not by you
you call me clever and i am you and your
mates haven't a clue that photo in the
paper gave me fits
and that bit about killing myself no
chance
i've got things to do my purpose to rid
the streets of them [ __ ] my one regret
is that
young lassie macdonald did not know
cause change routine that night
the letter went on for a bit in it the
writer identified himself
as jack the ripper and claimed
responsibility for eight killings
including one committed in preston in
1975.
this referred to the death of joan
robinson which police had long suspected
could have been a ripper murder it
wasn't
as they found out later but it wasn't
until 2010 that they actually identified
a true killer
thanks to dna evidence so did the police
think the letter was genuine
there were doubts of course but they
were somewhat assuaged by the fact that
the author played into their
preconceived notions that
the ripper hated prostitutes and that
the murder of jane mcdonald had been a
mistake
the writer also promised that his next
victim would be an older woman something
that turned out to be true
but it was the mention of the preston
murder that really sold the
investigators on the letter
as they mistakenly believed that it had
not been publicized
in reality everything in the letter was
public knowledge which was why the
author didn't take credit for the death
of yvonne pearson whose body had not yet
been discovered this should have been
a big red flag but the investigators or
the ripper squad as they came to be
known came to the conclusion that it was
genuine as were the two more letters
that followed over the course of a year
as for the actual yorkshire ripper his
next victim was vera millwood whom
he killed in manchester on may the 16th
of that year she was 41
older than most of the other victims
just like the letter promised atlantic
credence although
this turned out to simply be a
coincidence which benefited the real
killer
after beer and millwood's death the
ripper waited for almost an entire year
before striking again
but eventually he did strike again on
april the 4th 1979 when he attacked 19
year old josephine whitaker on her way
to her grandparents house in halifax
on her body the pathologists found
traces from a mineral oil used in
engineering
shops which was the same kind of oil
found on the envelopes that the lettuce
came in this was a
massive red herring but the police fell
for it hook line and sinker as they were
now convinced that the letters were
genuine they had a new lead to pursue as
the
had envelope been mailed in sunderland
so a quick english geography lesson here
as it will soon become
very very relevant the city of
sunderland is located further up north
than yorkshire where the murders took
place
this is an area known simply as the
north east of england the people there
are usually called geordies and they
have a very distinct dialect
police hoped that geordies and yorkshire
would stand out since their accents
were quite different so they went public
with this information then in june 1979
something new happened the writer was
not content with letters anymore so he
sent in a tape
on it in a thick geordie accent he said
i'm jack
i see you are still having no look
cutting me i have the greatest respect
for you george
good lord you are no need
to catching me now and four years ago
when i started
i reckon your boys are letting you down
george
they can't be much good can you
i'm not quite sure when i strike again
goody will be definitely sometime this
year
i am not sure where maybe manchester
united there there's plenty of them
knocking about
they i bet you've warned them
but they never listen the tape then
ended with a short clip from the song
thank you for being a friend by andrew
gold the george mentioned on the tape
was officer george
oldfield the man in charge of the ripper
squad at the time the police were now
convinced more than ever that this was
the real killer they brought in voice
analysts and linguistic experts and
they concluded that the man on the tape
spoke with an offshoot of the geordie
dialect called a weirside accent present
around sunderland and even narrowed the
area down further to a suburb named
castletown
the police went all in on this new lead
they launched a massive publicity
campaign as they pretty much warned
everyone in the country to
listen to the voice and read the
handwriting to see if they recognized
who it belonged to
thousands of billboards were put up all
over england adverts were placed in
hundreds of newspapers a hotline was
opened where people could call up to
listen to the tape the recording didn't
just play on television and radio but
everywhere there was a public speaker
system malls supermarkets
even nightclubs any attempts to suggest
that the ripper might not be a geordie
were ignored by the authorities
even when they came from his surviving
victims seven confirmed women had been
attacked by the killer and lived through
their ordeal some of them provided
evidence that directly conflicted with
the police's view of the ripper
so they were dismissed on the basis that
they either remembered incorrectly
or they had been attacked by somebody
else olive smelt the second victim from
1975 insisted that the ripper spoke with
a yorkshire accent
but a please fell on deaf ears we cannot
say with certainty that the ripper would
have been caught sooner if the police
weren't busy looking for a geordie but
we do know
that he was able to kill three more
women after the ripper squad launched
their failed publicity campaign
first was 20 year old barbara leech who
was killed on
the 1st of september 1979 just a few
months after the police
received the tape the following year the
ripper attacked four more women killing
two of them
margarite walls and jaclyn hill none of
his victims were prostitutes
walls was a civil servant while leech
and hill were students however the
police refused to change their view of
their target
or their strategy to catch him when the
ripper was finally apprehended in early
1981 it was a combination of dumb luck
and a lack of prejudice that finally did
him in for the first time the killer
went to sheffield in south yorkshire
looking for a victim ironically he did
this because he thought it would be
safer but it was what led to his capture
because the police there didn't
immediately dismiss a suspect
because he didn't have a geordie accent
he picked up a 24 year old working girl
called olivia rivers
and was on his way to a remote area when
he was pulled over by the cops and then
arrested
once it was revealed that his car had
false number plates
before being taken in he managed to
discard his weapons by pretending that
he was going to pee at the station
suspicions were
starting to grow the man had the right
shoe size he had the right blood type he
matched the physical description he
lived in the area of the murders
everything was lining up except for the
accent but the sheffield police decided
to ignore this in an
inspired move they went back and
searched the scene of the arrest and
they found the knife hammer and rope
that their suspect threw away
there was no more doubt they'd just
captured the yorkshire ripper
and his name was peter sutcliffe
so who was the man who had terrorized
the north of england for five years and
murdered 13 women he was born peter
william sutcliffe on june 2nd 1946
in bingley a market town in west
yorkshire the oldest son of john
suckleth and
kathleen conan he dropped out of school
when he was 15 and started working
various odd jobs including as a grave
digger and doesn't undertake his
assistant
eventually he trained to transport heavy
goods and became a lorry driver for a
company in bradford he married his
longtime girlfriend sonya surma in 1974
and began his killing spree soon after
once the world knew who peter sutcliffe
was
there was even more outrage at the
incompetence displayed by the police
they'd interviewed him nine times prior
to his arrest
he was one of the workers paid with the
money that included the bill found on
gene jordan's body he matched the
physical description provided by the
surviving victims he had been spotted
around the red light district of leeds
dozens of times
one of his friends named trevor birdsall
even came forward and
told the police that he suspected
suckler for being the ripper all of this
was ignored because peter sutcliffe
spoke with a yorkshire accent
not a drawdy one as for the man who sent
the tape and the letters and set the
police on the wrong path he became known
as weirside jack and it wasn't until
that he was finally identified his real
name was john humble and he was
sentenced to eight years in prison on
four counts of perverting the course of
justice as far as cyclif was concerned
his trial strategy was to plead to
manslaughter instead of murder on the
grounds of diminished responsibility
this would have made the difference
between spending the rest of his life in
prison
and going to a more relaxed mental
institution with hopes of even being
released one day
claiming that he started killing after
hearing the voice of god his lawyers
brought in medical experts who argued
that sucliff suffered from paranoid
schizophrenia neither the judge nor the
jury bought it and peter sucliff was
found guilty of murder and sentenced to
life in prison
he died on november 13 2020 shortly
after testing positive
the coronavirus so i'm not gonna ask
whether you enjoyed that video but i do
hope you found it interesting if you did
please leave a thumbs up below also why
not check out that podcast i mentioned
the casual criminalist it's also
available on youtube
i'll leave a link below and thank you
for watching